uh it is uh what time is it 20
37 minutes past 10 which means you're
watching the press preview our first
look at the front pages
as they come in the next few minutes
we'll be taking a look at what's making
the headlines with the economics
correspondent at the spectator kate
andrews and the editor of the sheffield
star
nancy fielder but before that let's take
a look at what's on some of those
front pages race to get aids to india
the metro leads with the news that the
uk is sending ventilators and oxygen to
help the crisis
in india meanwhile the government has
said a public inquiry into the uk's
handling of the coronavirus pandemic
is quotes not appropriate at the moment
adding that the very people who would
need to give evidence to an inquiry are
working round the clock that's according
to the guardian
at the front of the star beat eu to it
this the news that britain has secured
100 million doses of the french
coveted vaccine the prime minister's
former chief advisor dominic cummings
has been warned he isn't in the clear
over the chatty rat leak according to
the telegraph
but the express says that senior tory
mps want boris johnson to
rise above it and get on with the job
uh the yorkshire post reports on the
findings of a think tank
which says that the gap between rich and
poor is due to widen
as people rely more on inheritance than
earnings to get on in life
the ft says that some of credit
suissey's shareholders are going to try
and remove one of the company's board
members
after recent scandals at the bank and
the sun
features an exclusive interview with
rolling stones rockstar ronnie wood
about his battle with cancer during the
pandemic
uh well as you can see i'm joined
tonight by kate andrews and
nancy fielder ladies good to see you
again um
but let us start um nancy to you first
with it with the front of the metro and
a story that all of the papers will be
covering
and in some depth the absolutely
horrendous scenes
that we've been seeing here on the
channel reported by our special
correspondent alex crawford
i mean it's almost unbelievable
it is and i mean as you've said some of
the images we're seeing
are just absolutely devastating i think
there is nobody in their right mind who
thinks that we shouldn't be sending more
aid that countries like
england britain america france
all countries are in a position to help
need to be helping this
is killing people like we've not seen
before in
india and actually as we all know as
we've said all along
the world is not safe from this pandemic
until the whole world is safe you can't
say
britain is safe now we'll vaccinate it
it doesn't work like this so it's
absolutely right that we are helping
here we've i mean it's just absolutely
devastating scenes but
the wider picture is it's going to keep
happening in some of
the countries that are a long way away
but they really need our help and
actually it helps us too to help them
um kate to you i mean just in terms of
the story look plenty of
people plenty of people have noticed on
social media being vaguely sniffy about
the number of ventilators and
pieces of equipment that we're sending
like every one of them will at some
point save a number of lives so
you know we should bear that in mind but
it's the vaccine it's the vaccine
that india needs to get and i just
wonder whether whether you agree with
the argument but
bill gates and nancy just made it there
that look you know
we should not be vaccinating 30 to 40
year olds
at a time when india is seeing you know
hundreds of
thousands of new cases every day does
that argument make sense
i think it does make sense but it's a
difficult one to make
politically it's there's already a
precedent actually for
shipping some vaccines abroad the uk um
several weeks ago shipped hundreds of
thousands of vaccines it turned out to
australia
when the eu was making it very difficult
to export vaccines the uk stepped in to
get
uh those vaccines to our ally in
australia
and but they kept it very quiet they
didn't want this to be a news story of
generosity um of the uk coming to the
rescue because they knew it was very
politically difficult to be shipping off
vaccines that are here domestically to
another country now i think you can make
a very strong moral case
uh that we should be shipping not just
the 600 pieces of medical devices the
ventilators which will no doubt help
some people
but also vaccines as well to india to
get the most vulnerable inoculated and
to save lives the difficulty
is that the prime minister has laid out
a road map that is very long it's the
longest it takes to come out of a
lockdown so far
and that he says is dependent on the
data staying extremely low and that
includes getting more and more people
jabbed
now it's very hard to ask your public to
continue to put off
not just major life events but normal
daily events
when you're shipping vaccines abroad so
i think part of the political strategy
to come out of lockdown
is making it harder to probably do the
more ethical and right thing
which is to get the vaccines to the
people who really need it most to the
people
who are much more likely to be
hospitalized and sadly die from this
virus
i mean nancy as we we take a look at the
front of the financial times they're
their headline they're overwhelmed
india at covet breaking point and we we
are not even at the peak
of infections in in india at the moment
that that appears to be you know some
some distance away
but isn't it isn't the historical
relationship between the united kingdom
and india enough of a reason to do
that which the indians are calling out
for bill gates is calling out for
i mean boris johnson i keep keering as
you know is a fantastic communicator if
anyone could sell
sending vaccines to india surely it's
him
well you're right i mean historically
there is quite a weight on our shoulders
to help quite a few countries to be
honest but actually that shouldn't
matter should it we're talking here
about
are we opening pubs and going inside are
we going to festivals which
is fantastic we all want to boost our
economy we're talking about thousands
and thousands of people
dying and the question is what would we
want them to do
if we were in their situation and we all
know the answer but that isn't easy to
communicate i'm not sure it's the public
i think a lot of us actually think
that this is the right thing to do and
we should be doing more than we're doing
but there are certain elements and i'm
sure there are lots of them within
government who
fear that they would lose votes if they
did what
everybody can see is morally the correct
thing to do um okay
we can't we can't let a press preview go
past without a bit of palace intrigue
let's have a look at the front of the
daily telegraph and the
the dominant coming story continues um
to rumble on
i mean it's it's some time before he
appears in front of the select committee
but the story in the telegraph is an
interesting one tell us about it
so this is a continuation of the story
that has been exploding in westminster
over the weekend um in which number 10
suggests that dominic cummings was
responsible
uh for for certain leaks that had taken
place last year and also potentially
around some text messages sent
uh to boris johnson from sir james dyson
over a tax break as he was going about
trying to create
life-saving equipment at the height of
the pandemic last year
unsurprisingly dominic cummings pushed
back he published a very long blog
which raised big question marks and
really dropped bombs
on the prime minister and the government
around the refurbishing of his flat
around the leak inquiries and what
cummings says uh
number 10 and i'm sure uh would actively
deny it was a
was a desire to suppress one of the leak
inquiries because it might be tied
to the prime minister's fiancee's good
friend um and other just really
explosive claims
um now today on the telegraph we have
number 10 pushing back again saying that
dominic cummings is not cleared yet
um and we're going to see this battle
play out but a lot of the questions
around certain leaks that took place
last year
died down a bit now they're really back
on the political scene
and as you mentioned dominic cummings is
set uh to sit in an inquiry on the
government's handling of the pandemic
later on in may and in this blog he is
very critical of the prime ministers
handling the pandemic
not just about the leaks it's about the
overall sense what was happening in
downey street at the time
decisions that he's now saying he very
clearly disagreed with
um so the concern of course in number 10
is you know on the better side this
could be slightly
humiliating that one of his top advisors
is is pushing back in such a way but
of course if any of the allegations that
dominant coming set out
ended up being true the prime minister
could be in significantly home
hotter water uh than he would otherwise
be not just with the public but also
with his own party and the way that he's
been handling
the pandemic and other aspects of his
time in downing street
i mean it's still nancy the the headline
in the express after britain's sake get
on with the job i mean
there are certainly plenty of people who
are of that opinion it just seems to me
it's slightly difficult for
for the daily expression for others to
suggest that boris johnson needs to rise
above all of this
given the allegation that the prime
minister it phoned
personally phoned the editors of three
separate national newspapers
to brief them on the story
absolutely i think every one of us
agrees in part with this headline
get on with the job but actually we
don't want them to get on with the job
with all these scandals with all this
corruption it's like some sort of
hideous soap opera where you're just
wondering what's going to pop up next
these are the people who are supposed to
be running their country they're doing
it in our name
we've elected them as a country and
actually they should just be doing
much better this is why politics has got
such an awful name
this is why one in three of us can be
bothered to vote in the local elections
coming up and the rest of us can't
because everybody is sick to sick to
death of these kind of
vows and allegations and it's not about
getting on with so
being solving the covet issue solely
it's about cleaning up the act and
actually making us think that our
politicians are doing things on our
behalf
rather than these kind of scandals that
just go on and on
uh nancy kate we will pause there just
to take a very quick break
but coming up after it an oscar ceremony
unlike
any before uh that will be coming your
way after this
welcome back to the press preview kate
and nancy still with us indicate to you
first
take us inside the metro their page two
article about about
scam ads online thankfully i've not
fallen forward to any of those but i
know a fair few people who have
yes so throughout the pandemic scams
online and related to one's mobile phone
or landline phone
um have risen significantly as people
have been sitting at home on their
computers
um with their phones being their access
to the outside world during lockdowns
and this article in particular is
looking at some of those tech giants in
the role that they have played
um in in this article saying not doing a
good enough job
um in in tackling some of those scam ads
so it's singling out facebook and google
and saying that the consumer group which
found that 34
of victims who reported an ad to google
said it wasn't taken down and about a
quarter of
people who did so for facebook said uh
the same
and i think this is an interesting story
because if it hadn't been for the
pandemic focus on the czech giants would
have actually been
um much more intense it was a policy
area with the online harms and the
safety bill
that the government was really looking
at so you can see how this might have
come up
anyway in in in in one of those um in
one of those ways
uh but the fact that the pandemic has
meant that scamming has moved online
means that it's more pertinent issue
and for this area specifically and no
doubt as the pandemic hopefully soon
winds down as the vaccine factor so far
all the data suggests that it's
um it's going like gangbusters hopefully
means that we'll be able to tackle some
of these issues but also remove people
from these situations where they might
be more prone to scams
i mean nancy are you in any way such
surprised by this because i have to say
i'm
not i mean at the point at which
facebook google
you know are are threatened they'll have
the bottom line threatened
uh you know if they don't act and all
this then perhaps you'll see some action
until that point it's difficult to see
why they work
well absolutely and the same sort of
restrictions the same sort of action
will be taken against you at sky news or
was it a newspaper if we
publish things that weren't true and
even worse than that that were
deliberately targeting people
i mean these are internet sites of
massive
reach a massive influence and they
should be regulated
much more strictly what's really
depressing about some of the details
article is people just don't think
they'll take action so a lot of the time
they just don't even bother to report it
it's like kind of
they're happy putting up with it but
they're so powerful and so influential
why shouldn't they be regulated so that
we can all be kept a little bit safer
yeah don't hold your breath guys let's
have a quick look though at the front
page of the sun
um not the story of course there's a
really sad story in fact about
about ronnie wood but the story about
the oscars
of course my invites the vanity fair
party clearly got lost in the post this
year
is there any point to having the oscars
without the red carpet without all the
glitz the glamour
the champagne and the silliness uh what
do you think
i think it's important for the industry
which has taken such a beating
during the year of covid uh because
people just haven't been able to go to
the cinemas and even when they have
last year when we didn't have vaccines
it was something that people were loath
to do because of the safety concerns
so it's been a really difficult year i
think it's a nice opportunity
to celebrate the art in the film that
has still been made um
i think i'm right in saying that britain
has one of the largest numbers of
nominations in nearly 20 years
at the oscars so it's an exciting one to
look on certainly
looking different this year with almost
hubs created in different parts of the
world including la
and here in london on the south bank so
that people haven't had to travel
although they have wanted guests to show
up because
it's very difficult at the goals and
globes with it all on zoom okay
so sorry to have interrupted you there
but we are entirely
out of time